[Music]
all ron finley wanted to do
was plant some flowers and vegetables in
a dirt patch outside his house in south
central l.a
and he got a ticket for doing that for
gardening without a permit
which then led to a warrant for his
arrest
well
after he got through that
he's been turning dirt patches into
vegetable gardens ever since
and as a result he's completely
rejuvenated neighborhoods and
revolutionized education through his
gardening projects
so i wanted to talk to him
not just about gardening but what
gardening serves as a metaphor for how
we change our society change our
communities and revolutionize education
this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
i've been talking to you while you are
in your garden where exactly are you
exactly exactly i'm in um
los angeles south central los angeles
this is a swimming pool the place i'm in
used to be a
swim school so i turned the pool into a
garden that's amazing the thing is simon
i i tell people design the life you want
to live not the one that's been designed
for you you can take something and
change it to what you need it to be you
don't necessarily have to go anywhere
else to get it how old were you when you
sort of discovered the joy of gardening
because you know it's usually something
that people discover in their later
years i mean it's been different times
in different spaces that i've lived in
you know it happened after the
depression that they keep calling a
recession
you know it happened then
i was like damn it it was a relaxing
thing for me i i had um
what we call a parkway you know it's the
part of land between a street and a
sidewalk and see and some cities don't
have it some cities do we happen to have
them and i planted my parkway which you
know i wanted to come out simon and just
see beauty i wanted to feel beat i want
to smell beauty i want to see beautiful
flowers i wanted and it wasn't that much
food at first i had banana trees and
things like that on the street
that's where it started and
it just
and i got an arrest warrant
you know and um
the first time and then i told me i had
to take everything out everything i had
to put it back i had to put my weeds
back in the ground you know instead of
growing food you have to put the dirt
and weeds back replace them yeah
exactly and then years later i i formed
an organization i put it in again and so
it was going good
and i it was this time it was more food
and but also flowers also people would
just give somebody something to look at
and again a neighbor called and i got
another arrest warrant and uh i had to
go to court
twice and
that story ended good what got you the
arrest warrant wasn't necessarily the
police were coming around
looking to arrest you but your neighbor
complained twice i want to know what's
going through someone's mind when you're
beautying their neighborhood but they
prefer the dirt and the weeds have you
reconciled with that neighbor uh she's
not here anymore she was old and and i i
think she passed away she moved away but
i think she's passed away now but if she
wouldn't have done that i probably
wouldn't be talking to you right now but
i wanted people to see a difference i
wanted people to know that you
can take this opportunity that you have
the these resources that we don't call
resources and utilize them to the good
instead of leaving it like this because
what we do is we think things have to be
the way they are so i mean because
that's how it's designed we're supposed
to do this we're supposed to get on the
freeway every morning in in rush hour
you know so
my whole thing is we gotta shake all
that up man we gotta we gotta shake this
education system up definitely where we
tell kids that they are the most special
the most important the most brilliant
things the most beautiful the most
worthy and the most expensive things
because these kids think that [ __ ] they
can buy gives them
value yeah and it doesn't i heard a
story that jamie oliver told he had a
food program where he was bringing food
to i love jennifer inner city schools
because a lot of kids they're the main
meals that they eat are at school
and so he's like well let's let's make
that food healthy then
and he tells the story of going to one
of these schools
and was
absolutely shocked that all the kids who
were taking photos with him and of him
when he showed up all had the newest
whiz-bang iphone that money could buy
and yet at home they couldn't afford to
eat and he started asking those
questions like why is there a greater
value put on having the newest iphone
than there is on food no it's it's
terrible and i i speak to that i there's
there's a story that i was in um long
branch junior high school
and this kid everything was fortnite you
know i'm like come on guys this guy saw
the picture of the of the of the pool
where i'm at now and he says are you
rich and i said yes thank you i'm i am
rich but i said so are you you're very
you're rich so i'm i'm not rich i want
to be rich i said why you want to be
rich he said but then i could play
fortnite all the time and they all
screamed 450 ah i said no really why you
i said i know you want this you want
that and i said you want diamonds i said
a little ass up you say yeah i want
diamonds i said why you want diamonds he
said cause if i had diamonds that means
i'm rich i said really i said okay so
you have 550 000
and he goes yeah so i said okay and then
you go to the diamond store and it's
beautiful everything is shiny and gleamy
and lit and sparkly and you go to the
counter and say i want a diamond i have
five hundred and fifty thousand dollars
and i said okay so they bring your
diamond in this beautiful velvet box and
they hand it to you and you give them
your 550 000 and simon he goes yeah
and i said
and then i let him i did a three count
to myself i said what and then i said
got real close to the mic and i said
okay who's rich
there was this law just silence in the
audience then this big old crescendo
they went crazy and i told myself i said
got you a little ass yeah i said
you gave them your riches and they gave
you a rock that came from the mother
that came from the earth you don't
respect the earth but you only respect
what comes out of i said it's worthless
it's a rock like any other rock it came
from mother nature who i said your
nothing you can buy gives you value
nothing that you can buy is more special
than you nothing that you and i just i
just had a download and i went on one
with amanda to tell them you you have a
intrinsic value just being here on this
planet you know you social capital
community capital money is not the thing
that makes you rich i said you cannot
buy value and um and and they got it man
they heard me yeah you know so you take
people of all ages obviously but your
focus on kids coming in and
beautifying their own environment
planting
all kinds of things in any space they
can find in their neighborhood is that
right i tell people something i'll help
you but i'm not to help so don't get
that twisted you know what i'm saying i
want to show you how to me gardening
equals freedom
i want you to do this yourself i want
you to see how this feels i want a kid
to see this passion fruit seed and you
can barely see them and so to get this
and then all of a sudden you put in the
ground and you have hundreds and
hundreds of passion for that's magic
simon what else can you call that so
when a kid is exposed to that kind of
magic not once but over and over it
becomes normal for them where you they
see this and they they value this and i
made this can you tell me a specific
story of someone who
came and joined your garden and was
gardening who turned their life around i
mean it's a bunch of them i mean one of
the big stories is
this was dope i had no idea these guys
were following me in prison
and um so i met one of them he came out
i mean he did like 16 years and he drove
down from san diego came and said ron i
just had to drive down and meet you
because you changed my life
and uh you don't know me but i was
inside and i and i found this article on
you and i'm like damn so he said i just
did a deep dive on you and i said okay i
want to be like this guy when i get out
and uh he he wound up learning how to
farm and i didn't even just go garden
farm and so
at that same time at this event there's
a
we're talking i'm got my sunglasses on
crying under my sunglasses this other
guy comes up and he got he's been out a
year and he says um hey man uh
i am from another prison and i'm like
what the hell kind of day is this
and he's the same thing and what he told
his ceo he said release me to my uh
neighborhood because i want to change
the things that i screwed up in my
neighborhood so when he came up he said
i want to do what this guy is doing i
want to be like ron finley and he said
and he said man you don't have any idea
how many people are inside that that
look up to you to watch you that want to
be like you because he said we got
tricked with the og gangster guys you
know having us kids do the work why you
know why they skated and we the ones
that wound up doing the time so i mean
there's stories i got kids they used to
send me pictures from india assignment
and one
of them calling themselves gangster
gardeners like they 10 and 11 at the
time and their
[ __ ] and they get it they get the whole
what it ain't the gangster has nothing
to do with violence and and drugs and
alcohol and misogyny he has no i wanted
to change the vernacular with that word
no the soil is gangster this air is
gangster as hell you can't get no more
gangster than air you know what i'm
saying so being self-sustained being
self-regenerative that's gangster
teaching showing people how to change
their life that's gang stuff what's one
specific thing that you've been a part
of since you've been on your gardening
movement one specific event one specific
day or a person you've met that really
captures
why you do this that if every single
thing that you did every single weekend
was like this one literally you'd be the
happiest person alive
that's a hell of a question simon come
on
the first one that comes to mind and
this happened early on this kid and san
antone had his parents and him they took
up their grass in their front yard and
he called it his neighborhood grocery
stores they started growing food on the
parkway i mean not just on the parkway
but on their lawn and and i was like
damn people across the country literally
saw me talk and said okay i like what
this guy's doing mom let's tear it let's
tear up this grass and let's start
feeding our community yeah i mean come
on that's what about if we had an effect
on 20 of the population like that i mean
this like i said this is humanity man
this is a this is culture this is it we
treat it like it's frivolous this the
school should be in the garden not the
garden at the school yeah because
there's too much to learn in that garden
that's why i'm trying to take it man
it's like because in school we're being
indoctrinated we're being not being
educated no one's telling us to value
ourselves no one what's your earliest
specific happy childhood memory not like
we went to my grandparents every weekend
something something that i can relive
with you
ah
boy
they had this thing called pacific ocean
park back in the 1800s when i was a kid
and it was in santa monica
and i think just going there you know
from south central to the beach that's
that's a vision that came up
in my head when you asked that that's
the first vision that came up what
specifically about that memory as you
asked that i see the ferris wheel
spinning around
you know and it's right on the beach and
uh we just i just it just was fun man it
was i uh you know i mean one one of the
proudest moments is when i was a child
was in junior high i used to walk by the
cooking class the home eck you know they
used to put pies in the cakes in the
window to cool down
and i'm like
i need to be down with those pies you
know i need the chocolate chip cookie so
i went to the counselor and said i want
to take the cooking class and she said
you can't because that's for girls
and you know what am i 11
yeah 12 i don't know when i'm like
so i don't know where i pulled this from
something i said well aren't most men
chefs
and she goes
you know you're right
and so at horsemen junior high school
they started a boys cooking class
because i wanted hot chocolate chip
cookies i didn't realize that that was
paradigm no simon that's some paradigm
shifting yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah but as a kid
it was for one reason i could get hot
german chocolate cake now that was that
was pretty baller right there you know
that and that that it fell on her ears
was the beautiful thing because she
could have stayed with the status quo
yeah that's for girls you you need to go
to the wood shop there's a scum and
theme in all those stories you told me
from the cooking class and going to the
beach and even the story of the kid who
ripped up his lawn
it's about going to new places or
creating new spaces wow which is i can
go somewhere new or i can make somewhere
new around me
right
that's
that's crazy simon i wouldn't have
thought that
i mean it's so clear
where the world around us
and you you say this you talk around
this with the world around us isn't
necessarily the world we have to live in
and you can simply ask for something i'd
like to do that you can simply agree to
go somewhere i'll go to the beach
or you can just build it that's your
lawn you're actually allowed to do
whatever you want on your lawn and it
can just be a a lawn or it can be
something magical that you create
and i think the metaphor here
because you know the gardening that you
do and the gardening that you inspire
other people to do there's a metaphor in
all of that as well
which it's not just beautifying your own
space and making food and loving the
ground and finding community but it's
it's about it's about agency it's about
creating the life you want to live and
living in the space you want to live in
rather than society tells me i should
value this rock out of the ground and
someone spent all my money on a useless
rock
but i i create my own definition of
value and success and beauty and all of
this i i'm in love with the metaphor as
much as i'm in love with the actual work
that you do
thank you thank you no it's it's
it's funny that you put it like that
because and and i think a lot of it
comes from being dyslexic you know so i
mean because in school i could you know
i didn't read the way i was supposed to
and they just they still shuffle you
through and you know even though
you're not getting it like everybody
else but i'm so glad i didn't get it
yeah
i'm so glad
so do you consider yourself a gangster
gardener or do you consider yourself an
education reformer
to reform education you got to be
gangster sorry man
i mean because you got to think about it
we're dealing with some serious
gangsters here so we you can't come in
like tinkerbell you know with a wine no
people don't realize that it's a
perfectly oiled
machine and it works perfect but does it
work for us
i speak at architect schools
and things like that and i don't know
how the hell i wind up doing that and
i'll let first question i ask simon is
what are cities designed for
and then i just one time
in in atlanta
the professors got people like duh and
i'm going
wrong i said she's going to tell you the
cities of design for people she's wrong
i said the cities are designed for
commerce exactly period i said people do
not even they think about storing people
but they don't think about people's
health they don't think about people's
needs they don't think about people's
comfort you know or for having a
beautiful lifestyle
but you as architects you have to change
that instead of designing some
phallic building to represent you or
something you know and i'd ask that i
said you want to debate this and she
didn't have nothing to say
so
again that theme of of changing the
environment around us which is agency
yeah you know it's not about moving to
the inner city because that's as you
said where commerce where they built the
factories and they had to bring the
people close to the factories you know
the industrial revolution and it just
kind of stuck because then we built
offices and we built headquarters and
then as you said we sort of had to live
nearby and ta-da you've got a city
we can live a life by design or we can
live a life by default exactly
and i think most of us don't realize
that we have choices and the choices
aren't about quitting and moving and
like selling it that's not what it's
about as you've proved it which is if
you find a patch
of dirt outside on the street fill it
with something beautiful that you want
to look at because nobody wants to look
at a patch of dirt now what if that
patch of dirt was a friendship that you
could make more beautiful by filling in
the gaps what if that patch of dirt was
the way you feel about yourself and you
can find little beautiful things about
yourself and it's not about wholesale
change that like like a plant it grows
like you got to start with a seed and
then you water it and there's patience
gardening is a whole nother kind of
patience i mean it's the spirit of the
guard and it seduces you that it's it's
not instantaneous that's why i said the
the school should be in the garden we're
spinning around on a ball simon in outer
space looking for aliens but right now
we're spinning around on a ball
you know nobody thinks about that every
day and they should so uh
to me it's like we need to fix this we
have to fix this plan and we need to
stop trashing it and i think if we show
kids at an early age that you are nature
yeah okay you are a part of this planet
it's not nature in you you are a part of
this planet your energy your life force
your chi your prana comes from this
rotation of this ball that we're
spending around i always get a kick out
of when people you know you have a piece
of garbage and somebody says to throw
that away
like throw the like where exactly is
away
you know it's like i'm going to put it
here then i'm going to move it to the
front of my driveway or put it at the
outside the building and then somebody's
going to come and move it somewhere else
and eventually it's just going to get
moving but there's no actually a way
like there's no it just gets moved it's
like it's like blowing your leaves onto
your neighbor's lawn and be like there
we go
fixed i got rid of the leaves
this is what we don't actually throw
anything away we just take our problems
and turn them into somebody else's
problem right
[Music]
and then pay taxes for that no
no what and that's it's funny you said
the part about the leaves i tell people
a leaf falls for a reason in a
particular season that leaf is not
following falling on another tree it
falls right under that tree because it
has a purpose not only is it
photosynthesizes the sun and feeds the
tree and directs the rain and the
moisture when it happens and a leaf has
a lot of purposes so then after finish
that season change it falls to the
ground now it becomes mulch okay when
the season change now it becomes it
turns into compost
okay so it returns in the soil yeah and
it starts all and it's a circle that
continues on and on and on to change
subjects you're teaching kids about
self-reliance you're teaching kids about
changing their environment you're
teaching kids patience
what about health uh it's one of the big
topics that these days where because
because cheap food is [ __ ] food you know
generally mcdonald's and stuff yeah are
you teaching kids to change the way they
eat not just the things they buy that's
the thing with this garden if a kid
grows kale they're going to eat it
because now they have skin in the game
you know so and now they know where it
is and they saw the magic when they put
that carrot seed in the ground and all
of a sudden it's a carrot and it's like
i made this you got them you know so now
now now they're vested in it but yeah
it's
not only do you show them eat you show
them how to cook
you know that's what i'm saying i
learned you know i had a cooking class
in in junior high school you know so why
why why aren't we showing them how to
grow food harvest food and cook food i
mean again
that's another trade that's that's a
bunch of different trades right in there
that these kids can be self-reliant they
don't have to be uh dependent on
anything but yeah that that's the big
part of it but you don't go in
necessarily with that uh one of the
things i do with these kids when i when
i go to school is um i'll uh
i'm like i brought you guys some snacks
yeah
a bait and switch well i have somebody
buy pass them out simon have somebody
pass them on i have two mics set up i
say but you can't eat them oh i said
what i want you to do i want you to turn
the package over and i want you to get
on your phone and i want you to look up
what these words mean and what are they
related to and it's always oh this is
related to acne irritable bowel syndrome
and this thing and this is you know made
from beaver anuses and it's an ice cream
and makeup and it's like all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] and it's and it's always this
kid that gets up that they can't
pronounce this word yeah and i'm like
i've been waiting for you the whole
thing has been about you i've been
waiting for you and i said
really because
if you can't
read that [ __ ] don't eat that [ __ ] i
said nothing in nature has 16 letters
that you can't pronounce okay so it's
like man-made and and i get them like
that man because they realize they're
they associated oh i got acne and i'm
eating this or you know i got irritable
bowels in them and a lot of the stuff
this gives you cancer so why are they
why are they allowed to put this in our
food yeah why are they allowed to give
you cans why are they allowed to keep
you sick and that's you know it's not
it's not health care it's sick care yeah
how often do you garden is it every day
every week oh my god yeah i mean at some
point i mean because it's maintenance
man this is a it's amazing but the thing
i tell people be the forest because if
you guard in like the forest who's who's
gardening in the forest the forest does
what it's supposed to do you know and
and people oh this is junky i'm like do
you go to the forest and say oh this is
junky it's a damn forest this is how
they look so i try to i try to do
biomimicry which is replicating what
nature does so a lot of times if you do
that you don't have the weeds you don't
have the soils being built because
you're you're leaving stuff right there
where it falls right where it's supposed
to and that's why why do we go out and
buy forest soil the soil is from the
forest you can make your own forest i
mean if i could take you guys on the
parkway you see i mean i have i have
banana trees orange trees pear trees
apricots plums just growing on the
street what's one place that you want to
plant a garden that you have not yet
been able to get to to plant in every
school in the world
i think every school in the world needs
to have a garden and they should be
everywhere um
and why aren't they why aren't we
showing these kids
nutrition why are we showing these kids
self-reliance why are we showing them
you know we're training greedy bastards
from day one if you had this you and you
lived here if you this makes you special
so now you got these kids thinking i
need you're showing it and flashing all
that [ __ ] in front of their face
but you're not giving them the access to
it i mean you got to think some people
in this world are bonds for the all
these industrial complexes from the
prison
to the army to you know to the health
industrial complex you know they're not
showing they're not showing really
people how to how to get well they're
showing you how to maintain there's that
pattern again which is here's the dirt
and you can accept the dirt and take a
pill to continue to look at the dirt or
every single one of us has the agency to
change our lot literally and
figuratively
god blessed sir ken we we all love him
and admired him um and i firmly believe
that the torch of education and reform
that he held has been handed to you oh
you are carrying that towards me you're
about to make me you're about to make me
cry you are doing it your way he did it
his way that's too big dude and you're
doing it you're right
it's true you you i mean listen to your
words you want to have a you want to
have a garden in every school you want
to change every kid's life i mean you're
teaching kids agency and you're doing it
and the mechanism the mechanism is
gardening but that's because that's
where you come from exactly you know
it could have been something else if you
came from somewhere else and you are as
far as i'm concerned ron i look i love
your story i love the gardening story
but the thing that inspires me more than
anything else is you are reforming
education how we think about education
and how we think about how to treat
children and what children need to think
about for their own futures and that
they have agency and choice
for the world that they live in that's
what makes it dangerous that's what
makes it gangster is because as you know
science i tell people imagine yourself
free but imagine if people had free
thinking instead of thinking
in this so-called box you know ain't no
[ __ ] box you know let's just just
think and be free but you would it just
seems to me that the world would be such
a better place you know if people didn't
you don't realize that somebody's foot
is on your neck yeah ron you are
you are
just an inspiration a magician
i'd like to bring my niece and nephew
out would you please
no without question make that happen
that's what we do good i want them to
learn how much agency they have in life
we all need to realize that and i think
if if if we train these kids that they
have value they would realize i don't
really need those shoes i don't really
need that phone i don't really it's like
because i i have value in myself yeah
you know and and no one's who no one's
teaching that simon no one's no one i
can i can think of one person
oh yeah
whatever
no but not but not
not
stop dude stop
not uh not the way it should be not on
the scale that it should be man it's i
mean i don't know it's just and i think
it's a lot
because of how i was raised and what i
wish the way i raised my sons man i got
three sons and people like you're so
hard raising kids i'm like it's oh shut
up it's not hard you know most people
become their parents and i'm like no
that wasn't cool there was no violence
there was no drugs there was no alcohol
i said let me take all of this stuff
that was in my household and and see
because i tell my kids you guys are test
tube your baby your experiments you know
and
i'm three for three so i wanted to let
them know that operate from happy basic
if the [ __ ] don't make you happy don't
do it and so
what they're doing is just that so i
took all those
negative things out that a lot of people
don't see as negative because this is
this part of my life this is how i grow
and it works man if you're there if
you're there and you show up and it's
not hard what was your household like
when you grew up and and how was the
household like
that you have with your three sons
different there was uh love expressed
there was no violence there was no beat
so there was nobody you brought that
love to your home i get to eat dinner or
breakfast and lunch with them like i
took them to school i was you know i was
the the black parent that dropped this
kid off you know
at the school at ucla and so stuff like
that man and i was there you made a
difference you're involved yeah yeah and
it wasn't hard so i'm you know it and
people said kill me how they say oh it's
oh it's so dead i said no it's what's
difficult about it you know stop trying
to make them do what you did it's like
because i tell people you know you're
going to be a doctor because your dad
was a doctor and his dad i'm like dude i
want to be a ballerina leave me can i do
what i want to do so now you put them in
school and they're miserable because you
got them doing what you want that you
what you didn't accomplish ron you are
one thing if not consistent
you you don't have to be a doctor you
can change your environment you can
change
you are consistent ron such a such a
pleasure such a pleasure thank you so
much for taking time come on uh and
we're gonna we're gonna garden together
soon make it happen all right
baby
[Music]
if you're interested in learning more
about ron finley
or donating to the ron finley project
visit ronfinley.com and follow him on
instagram at ron finley hq and at ron
finley project
until then take care of yourself
take care of each other
you